All right. Shuli Gilutz,
thank you so much for joining me.
Great to be here or there. Somewhere.
Who knows anymore.
Shuli, what does it mean to be an expert
on Children’s User Experience in digital?
What does that mean?
It's a great question
because I don't know if the word digital,
like how that refers to user experience,
but generally what we look at is how
to design environments, digital
environments, interactive
environments for kids
which are age appropriate.
So, age appropriate design.
It started out with a more cognitive focus
in terms of learning and attention,
but today we talk about social, relevance,
and emotional
and all these other challenges
that we have in designing.
So okay. So, when you talk about children,
what demographic are you an expert on?
Which demographic are we talking about?
So children zero to 18
that's the legal boundaries.
Even though research today talks about
childhood ending at around 25. So -
I'm still a kid! Great!
- Sorry all those out there
Finally, I have confirmation
that I can be a kid again.
Wonderful.
You are. But legally 18.
I guess it depends in different countries.
Some countries legal age
for different things
varies. The US 21 for some things,
but legally zero to 18.
So you know it's such a confusing time,
and it's such a fascinating time
to think about this
because I'm looking at all these
social media apps that are arising.
And it's incredible to see how,
I'm 24. I consider myself a child still
and a very young user,
yet I use Facebook primarily
then Instagram.
I don’t really know what Tiktok is,
but I heard that I'm supposed to be there.
But it's crazy because already I feel
illiterate when it comes to the usage
of how young people use social media
and interact with it overall.
So, tell me a little bit about
what is the study that you're doing?
And what are the differences between
the way that young people
use these things
versus the older generations
like myself?
So that's, exactly that's a great question
because you would not be considered
an old generation. You're a millennial.
I mean you're the younger generation
right? But what we see now is fascinating.
I've been in this field for about 20 years.
And we've always divided up kids
to five age groups, right.
So, you have your babies, your toddlers,
early elementary, tweens, and teens.
You'd think that that would be enough.
But apparently, it's not
because it turns out that every five years
there's this jump in technology
and what happens is
is not that the children become smarter.
Evolution doesn’t happen over five years
it happens over millions of years.
So what the difference is
is that when they're born with
certain technologies as a baseline,
they start from there,
and that's what the minimum
they expect everything
to work in a certain way.
So, you can even see with kids today,
like I have two children one is 13
and one is almost 10.
So my 13 year old, when he searches,
goes primarily to text based search,
YouTube, other place.
My 10-year-old, when she was very young
when she was four, YouTube Kids came out.
And I showed it to her.
And it has voice search.
So she would go, "Elsa."
and it would play Let It Go whatever.
She uses voice search today.
She can write. She could do anything.
It's a very, it just opened kind of a gap.
And he never uses voice search.
Why would he use voice search?
He could type.
But he's 13. So, you see already those
a few years have very different behaviors
and we see that with voice a lot today.
Kids growing up with Alexa at home,
and Google home, and Siri,
they treat voice very naturally,
while kids who are just a few years older
and old 20-year olds like yourself,
are like, "Okay. Maybe I'll use Siri here.
Maybe I'll use voice there"
But younger kids, it's just so natural to them
because it was always there.
Like their Legos and like their other books.
It was even there before they were able
to read and write, they were able to speak
and therefore if that's an option
on YouTube Kids then that becomes
their default way.
Exactly. And they're just used to it.
And when adults use it, they are like
"Okay. What should I say?
What's the command?
What's the right thing to do?"
Yeah. I think that's fascinating
because it's been, it must be already a few years.
My father is at Google and I've seen him
talk to his Google assistant
and I hate voice.
I can’t do voice.
I don't do the right command.
My phone doesn’t understand me.
I feel so old when it comes to these.
So, now I'm thinking that he's a revolutionary
that in his great age and he's been
using it for years. But it makes sense
that the new generations,
that's what they're gonna be adapted to.
So, this is where we should capitalize.
So, what else?
What other -
But I have to say though,
in defense of your father,
who is not a typical in his generation
I would say.
But actually voice is very big
with the older generation, with older adults
because it, again, allows them
to do things that maybe is harder
for them in other ways.
So, they are actually
early adopters in that area
which is really interesting.
I mean there are a lot of
parodies if you've seen the SNL ones
and others,
but voice is very big. And in many ways
I have this colleague who talks about
designing for older adults
and a lot of times we find ourselves
together in conferences.
Me talking about kids
and him talking about older adults
- Oh, that's awesome.
- ... there's a lot of similarities
Oh, that is so cool. Yeah.
Very interesting.
But the thing about kids is that
they're not afraid.
So, that's why kids are such great learners.
They take a phone and say,
"Hmn, what will happen if I put this
in the toilet? You know that would be cool."
And the parents are like, "Aaahh."
And they put it in and
then you have to put it
in rice and whatever.
Just so you know, rice works.
But they're curious
and they try everything.
So, when you try everything
you figure it out.
That's how you learn the best.
When you're like,
"Oh my God, what will I press?
What do I do?"
Then you don't learn anything.
Then it's much slow.
It's not that they're smarter.
It's just they're more open.
They're not afraid.
They don't care that it costs so much.
That's why they're great learners.
And especially with technology,
and also the fact that they're not,
especially the younger kids,
they're not really aware to
what we mean by technology.
Like if you talk to young children, you ask them,
"You know, what's your favorite technology?"
They would be like,
"The refrigerator. The car."
Technology's everywhere. Right?
The distinction between digital,
that's what I said UX digital,
and non-digital
is a very old distinction.
It's an adult thing.
'cause you work in high tech.
Whatever that means.
They don't care you're creating stuff
for fun, for game, for learning, for play.
They don't care if Lego has sensor
or it doesn’t have sensors. Is it a fun game?
Yeah. That's what they care about.
So, these distinctions are very like
top down and very adult
and not relevant to their lives.
They are looking at the final product
and it's pure UX.
Like what's the experience here?
Is it a great learning experience?
Is it a fun experience?
Is it motivating?
Do they wanna play it more?
They don’t care if it has sensors, or digital
or whatever in it or not.
Right. So, you're teaching at Shenkar
and Tel Aviv University.
And what do you focus on?
And what do entrepreneurs
today who are building products
that are going to be used by kids
or other demographics,
is this something that they need to
keep in mind and really understand
the different user experiences?
Is there a really clear distinction?
Yeah. I think that's two different things.
I think students at Tel Aviv University
and Shenkar, they're very interested in this.
They see what's happening around them.
They can tell the difference.
They don't really know
how to gauge it exactly.
You know, are people are into Minecraft
or Fortnite
these days? Or is it Tiktok
or Snapchat. Like, what's going on?
And it's fine and it's exciting.
But I think, the important thing for
entrepreneurs is really to understand
that there's a variety of kids.
I've worked with so many companies
that come and say,
"Okay my kid, they love reading on an iPad
so I'll develop a blah blah blah blah"
Okay.
Let's see what their age group.
You know how many kids,
what's developmentally appropriate?
So there are all these myths that we really
have to do ... user research to,
but like with any other UX
and any other product,
to tease them apart.
There are a lot of myths
about kids and technology.
And unfortunately,
the biggest one is screen time.
Everybody is afraid of screen time
especially in the valley.
And I think it's really interesting because
there is no such thing as screen time.
If you look at,
I gave my kids 20 minutes
of screen time today.
What does that mean?
Were they watching 20 minutes
of Sesame Street?
National Geographic? Or porn?
Were they watching reality TV
or sports? Was it Dora?
What does that even mean?
It's like you would never,
you know in a book or any other game,
it's about the content
and then the context.
What are the alternatives?
Now 20 minutes of screen time
can mean talking to grandma.
You know because you can’t go visit her.
So is screen bad?
Right.
So it's really about the content,
the context, and the alternative. Right?
And also the specific child.
What's the age group?
What are their capabilities?
What do they need in their lives?
So, I think by boxing it all on screen time,
we're really doing a disservice for our kids.
And also, we're kind of not looking at ourselves
because as the adults around the kids,
we're on this thing all the time.
Not 20 minutes. Not 20 hours,
but 24 hours 24/7.
And there's so many surveys to show that.
So, these kids are growing up
in a very different childhood
than you grew up in,
than I grew up in for sure
where everybody's connected
all the time,
and they wanna be like the adults
around them.
So, it's not fair to judge them and say
"Oh, but when I was a kid
we use to play outside all the time."
Right. Because you didn’t have this
super computer library in your pocket
all the time and neither did your parents.
or your siblings, or your friends,
and everybody else.
Very different childhoods especially 2020.
This, everything's changed -
- This acceleration is amazing. Right.
I mean amazing in the sense
that it's remarkable. I don't know if it's,
I don’t know what it's going to be on kids.
But one of the things that
I’m curious about,
so we talked about this trend that
kids are much more into experimentation
and as the generations grow older,
the will or the excitement
about experimentation decreases or
there's an increased anxiety or fear.
Are there other key differences
that you've noticed
between the usage of kids
versus the usage of adults?
And something that product designers
or entrepreneurs can keep in mind
as they're designing their products
for the different demographics?
Yes. Definitely.
So, number one I think
the most important one is motivation.
So when you're designing a product
for adults,
your motivations are a lot of times
utility. You wanna be efficient,
you wanna get time on task
is a measure.
You check your ROI according to
how much time you saving,
how much money you're saving.
With kids, it's just not the case.
Again, it depends on the age group,
the content, and the context,
but a lot of times, kids are using
technology for fun, for entertainment,
for learning.
They will spend an hour watching
something that you think is not of value
but for them it's huge.
And if you really wanna empower them,
and give them the ability to create
like drawings, so if they're drawing a ...
if they're creating stop-motion animation
or if they're creating video games
that they're programming.
That will take hours.
So, it's not about efficiency
which is very important.
It's a very different thing
when you're doing UX for adults.
Efficiency is a very big thing.
So motivation, intrinsic motivation,
things that I'm passionate about
while adults a lot of times have
external motivation. Things for work.
Changes the ability.
There was a bid trend of gamification a few years ago.
I think that's gone down a bit
'cause people understand that
once you're doing things for badges and
leaderboards and stars,
that becomes the motivation and
you forget about
what you're actually loving to do.
So, even in places like Khan academy
and places that have really
kind of novel ways to treat education
are doing great things,
they've lowered the gamification of it
- Really?
so the focus is still the content.
So, gamification works.
No doubt about it. It works.
- 100%
It just changes the focus
from the content
So for different people
it does different things.
Interesting. But I do have to say that
I was looking for motivation to finish
a course on Khan Academy back
when I was in high school.
And I was doing self-study
for advanced math.
And the fact that I had those badges
and I had that streak.
All of sudden it kept me from
exiting a video because I knew that if
I just listened to the last two minutes,
which are always important because
that's where you usually
have the summary,
but we think,
every kid thinks
he's the smartest kid in the world.
So you think "Ah I don’t need to listen
to the summary. I got it"
But I wouldn’t have received my
extra 90 tokens if I didn’t stay on.
So I stayed on and I'm very thankful
that I did that.
Shuli, talk to me a little bit
about your work.
What does it mean to be
an expert on user experience for kids?
Do you work with startups?
Do you teach? How does it work?
So okay. So, I have a few different bits
to my work.
I'm very inter-disciplinary
I got one foot in academia
one foot in industry.
I don’t really fit anywhere.
But I really enjoy it
'cause I love theory
and I love research
and I love thinking about products
that just benefit kids
without have to thinking
about marketing, sales,
and all of that stuff.
However, I like doing things
in the real world that
actually reach kids too.
So trying to do both.
I consult companies who develop
products for kids.
These could be AR, VR,
and apps like digital TV apps.
Or now I'm working with a company
that's developing an online platform
for education.
So, when they're doing
these products we do the full UX process.
So we think about who are the stakeholders?
Who are the users?
Where are their painpoints, the ...
the journey,
but we do add the unique factors
of designing for kids and for families
which go together with designing
for Children's Rights
which is another organization
I'm part of. And thinking about
what this affords them?
What this really gives them?
More than only what they need
'cause needs is again, it's a very adult kind of a word,
our painpoints,
that means you have a goal
and you have an efficiency and so forth.
And there are also
some legal considerations
of course to consider,
data, privacy, security,
when you're designing for kids
which are slightly different
again, depending on the
different age groups.
When you said the word children’s rights
immediately my thought was
How do you design responsibly for kids,
not just in terms of the legal aspect
on the data and privacy,
but also in terms of,
it's much easier I think,
I'm assuming, to get a kid addicted to
something than it is
to get an adult addicted
because the adult has those firewalls,
those internal firewalls, that tell them
"Uh-Oh, I'm actually spending too much time here
or I'm not doing the right thing"
A kid may not have that.
So, what is the responsibility here
in terms of understanding
how to design responsibly for kids?
So, ethics are big.
So, you hit the point.
I mean adults have that or not,
but we can’t, they're adults.
They can do whatever they want.
We do have legal protection
for different things,
from gambling to other things,
but we know that there are ways
you could use dark UX
to create addictions and so forth.
Now, for kids that's worse because -
I like that term. Dark UX.
Dark UX. There you go.
Look it up. You'll find creepy stuff.
But for kids, especially younger kids,
they don’t even know
that some things are ads.
I mean I had this conversation with my son
a few years ago
when one of his favorite youtubers
was showing him something
with Lego or Minecraft I don't remember.
And I told him,
"Well you know he gets paid for that."
He looked at me he's like,
"What?"
I said, "Yeah,
you know they're promoting it."
And I said,
"You know I like this youtuber.
I really do. He's awesome.
He picks really good products.
I like the way he does stuff.
That's why I let you watch him,
but you should know that Lego
paid him to go to Legoland
to get this stuff."
He started crying and he's like,
"How can you say that?
This is just what he loves."
So we had now,
of course, my kids,
they're involved in my career.
So they know what’s going on.
But a lot of kids don’t.
You know they believe that these influencers
are passionate about this stuff.
Now, some of the stuff that
youtubers pull are awesome.
A lot of environmental stuff,
a lot of great stuff.
But they are promoters
of all kinds of efforts
and there's no way,
and TV, in linear TV, there used to be
"We'll be back after these messages"
Right? When you were watching a show
and you were going to commercials.
That was a way to tell children
okay, the cartoons you're seeing now
are ads.
The cartoons you saw before are content
'cause how would they distinguish it
they have the same characters.
There's a Spiderman here and Spiderman there.
It’s the same.
In internet and digital,
we don’t have that linear experience.
So you have to be very responsible.
There's a lot going on in terms of ads
and kids’ apps, and paid stuff,
and different models for it.
But yeah, you have to be aware
of these things and think about it,
and think about what kind of experience
you want to create for your users
ethically not only legally.
I think two things came to mind
when you were giving that example
of my beautiful niece
who's now five years old
but this is already relevant
from when she was three
that she would watch these
unboxing videos on YouTube.
And when I saw that,
I thought it was the
most ridiculous thing.
I couldn’t believe that we're watching
another kid unbox a toy now.
And then I looked at how many
views and it had a billion views.
It was one of the most
popular videos on YouTube.
And then every time
on YouTube there was the ads
that come up in the middle.
She would go furious.
She would say, "I don’t understand.
How do I exit out of this?
How do I skip?"
And I thought it was just incredible
because I grew up
Saturday morning I go to the TV,
and I watch my cartoons
and I wait. And I wait for the cartoons
and whatever happens happens.
Right. But that's a great point
because first of all the cartoon thing,
yeah they don’t get the whole
why do we have to wait
and why do I have to watch?
But the adults don’t get it either.
So, they're good.
They're along with everything.
But the thing about the unboxing
and there's a lot been written about that
but it's really cool.
So if you think about play patterns.
Play patterns don’t change across media,
but if you think about peek-a-boo, right,
it's the same thing. It's unboxing.
So, you're just walking and, "Wow! Surprise!"
And then another one.
"Wow! And I wonder what's gonna be
in there now." So, it's so exciting.
We call it unboxing because
we have no clue what's going on there.
But for them it's just a surprise show
after surprise after surprise
which is really cool.
You know how when kids get gifts
they say that
the box part is the best part
they play with the cardboard.
- Yeah!
That's it. Over and over again.
It's amazing.
It's perfect.
That is so so cool.
Are there different things
that we should be worried about
with the way that generations are moving
and interacting with technology?
Should I be worried about
some of the things that my niece
is going to experience different
from the way I will
whether in terms of social interactions,
or personal fulfillment,
or emotional intelligence?
Well yeah, but it's hard to say what.
So I think the problem with that is that
a lot of parents today
don’t know what their kids are doing.
They can’t deal with it.
Parenting is hard. You're parenting,
your kids are doing stuff you haven’t
done when you were a kid.
They're not watching Saturday
morning cartoons anymore, or
maybe they are but they're doing
a million other things.
And so, you have to learn
what they're doing.
What's right and wrong.
What's going on.
It's really really difficult.
So, a lot of parents are like just
do whatever you need to do.
Let me know if I have to buy something.
And that's a bit problematic
because you would never let your kid
just go around the street
and go to people you don’t know.
And there could be things that are not
for them or dangerous.
Or even if you let them play like
I had a mom, I talked about Fortnite and
how I thought it was actually
a pretty cool game for tweens.
And she was so angry and she said
"You know my kid you should see him after
he plays eight hours of Fortnite.
He's like a zombie."
And I'm like,
"Why is he playing eight hours of Fortnite?"
One hour. Two hours.
With his friends that's awesome.
It's a game that has diversity.
You play with groups.
You're assigned gender and ethnicity,
random. There's no blood.
There's sweet little cute animals.
There's dances.
Eight hours? Like eight hours?
So and I think,
'cause she's like, "Ah, yeah
he's playing with his friends"
So, I think the problem for the kids
is not the technology per se,
but the problem is the parents
are kind of stuck. They don’t know.
They don’t know enough about
when to say yes.
They have to sit down
and play with their kids.
They have to know what Fortnite really is.
What Minecraft really is.
And then they’ll know how to parent it.
Like they do with anything else.
There’s no other way
because it keeps changing.
It's like you said about Tiktok.
Today it's Tiktok.
Two years ago it was Snapchat.
Two years ago it was something else.
It's gonna be something else soon
'cause too many adults are in Tiktok.
The teens are gonna leave.
They don’t want adults there.
Really, adults are going on Tiktok?
Oh yeah. All these moms are trying
to be cool.
And all these companies are trying to
use Tiktok as a platform
for products of course.
So, the minute that happens
you know it's gonna shift soon
in some way.
But the thing is that,
parents have to know.
So, my advice would be
just sit down and play.
Don’t read articles whatever.
Just sit down and play with your kids.
Just see what's going on.
What do they do?
They'll love it.
They wanna talk to you about these things.
Fascinating.
And if they're at the point where they don’t,
where they’re teens already,
that's difficult. But still, be there with them.
Just show them you care.
Show them that you're into it
'cause once you dismiss it all as screen time
or "Oh c'mon I don’t understand about that"
then you're just creating a bigger gap
and it's harder to parent that way.
100%. Shuli, 20 minutes go by
so so fast, but I have to ask you the most
important question. Three words that
best describe you.
... okay. One I guess it would be
interdisciplinary because I don’t know
what I do.
The other one would be curious 'cause
I'm always interested in what’s going on.
And the last one would be an optimist
because I really believe it's all good,
and it's gonna better
Wow. Most people when they talk
about this the way that kids
interact with technology
and the addiction, they're very,
they're on the opposite spectrum
of optimism.
Because they haven’t talked to kids.
You know what, that's what I love about what I do.
I get to sit and talk to them,
and play with them,
and they’re the best.
That's amazing. Shuli, toda raba.
Thank you very very much.
Toda. Stay safe and stay healthy.
Thanks. Bye.